bloodborne barrier is a cellular barrier  that protects the brain from harmful  substances present in the blood it acts  like a diffusion barrier at a cellular  level it is composed of capillary  endothelial cells parasites astrocytic  infants and the microglial cells at a  molecular level the tight junctions  between the capillary endothelial cell  serves as the barrier  it allows the passage of CO2 O2 this  kind of gaseous molecules and there are  Transporters which allows glucose  transport but it prevents diffusion of  harmful metabolites antibody complexes  and immune cells inside the brain  blood-brain barrier is affected in many  diseases such as Alzheimer's disease  point to be noted bloodborne barrier is  very different from blood CSF barrier  and not all blood vessels display  bloodborne barrier like capabilities  want to know more subscribe to the  channel